♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, il motivetto jazz che funge da sigla alla serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪
Benvenuti ad un nuovo episodio del "Late Show con Karim Musa"!
Io credo di... adorare le idee:
ogni volta che guardo un film, un telefilm, leggo un fumetto o un libro, oppure gioco ad un videogioco,
sono curiosissimo di sapere cosa ci sia dietro. Ovvero, quale sia stata la scintilla che ha dato il via a quel determinato progetto;
perché noi (la maggior parte delle volte) ci soffermiamo alla realizzazione del progetto,
a come è stato fatto il progetto,
Ma mai alla cosa che l'ha fatto partire, quel progetto; secondo me, è  infinitamente più interessante.
Proviamo a prendere il concetto di idea, e a trasformarlo in un... "nocciolo di un oliva": tu ti gusti la tua oliva,
(bella, da mezzo chilo, di quelle pugliesi, belle grosse, verdi fosforescenti) e poi butti  il suo nocciolo nel cestino.
dimenticandoti che tu hai gustato un'oliva proprio grazie al nocciolo,
che era la parte centrale che ha sviluppato tutto quello che vi era intorno.
Esattamente come un'idea.
Con sto esempio il video è partito alla grande... ottimo.
Però spero di avervi fatto capire cosa intendessi io per quanto riguarda la mia curiosità
nel cercare la benedetta idea dietro un progetto
E se tu ti andassi a cercare effettivamente in mezzo alle tue passioni, cosa
ha spinto le persone a creare quello che ti piace di più nella tua vita,
scopriresti delle cose incredibili.
Prendiamo un esempio di idea, che io adoro nel mondo della musica
la canzone "Inside the Fire", dei "Disturbed".
E' una canzone del 2008, tratta dall'album "Indestructible"; e questo brano è un pò particolare
perchè tratta il delicatissimo argomento del suicidio.
Ovviamente, senza neanche bisogno di dirlo, non è né la prima né tanto meno l'ultima canzone
che tratta di suicidio: ci mancherebbe altro.
E, allora, perchè mi piace in particolare questa di idea che sta dietro tale canzone..?
Be', allora... Per contestualizzarvi meglio: il cantante David Drayman, quando avevai 16 anni, si è ritrovato a dover affrontare il suicidio della sua fidanzata.
E io non posso neanche lontanamente immaginare cosa abbia passato in quel periodo.
E lui dopo svariati anni, e dopo aver cercato il modo più adatto per trasportare gli ascoltatori di quella canzone all'interno del baratro che ha passato lui
lui ha trovato un'idea. E in questo caso, analizzando anche il testo, l'idea è
il punto di vista da cui viene raccontata questa storia. Che poteva essere: il suo punto di vista e tutte le emozioni che lui ha provato
in quel momento, oppure sarebbe potuto essere il punto di vista di lei e quello che lui immaginava stesse passando in quel momento
Ma non è così: il buon David decide di raccontare l'accaduto dal punto di vista... del Diavolo.
Il Diavolo Tentatore che aveva accanto a lui quando è successo il fatto. Che gli sussurra nell'orecchio:
"Dammi la tua anima, se vuoi rivedere la tua ragazza".
Ecco. Vi chiedo umilmente scusa nel caso vi abbia procurato dell'angoscia.
Magari voi pensavate, una volta pubblicato un video di Yotobi, che "daje, se ride stasera!"...
E poi, invece, vi ritrovate sdraiati in posizione fetale sul divano di casa vostra, in questa serata.
Mi dispiace, però per me questa risulta essere un'ottima idea: è un'idea curiosa;
e io, ogni volta, impazzisco nello scoprire quale sia il fulcro centrale che si nasconde dietro a qualcosa che mi piace.
Vi porgo un altro esempio: allora, nel periodo iniziale di Youtube
(e con iniziale intendo proprio i suoi inizi, quindi il periodo 2006-2007-2008... proprio i primissimi anni della piattaforma)
non c'era un cazzo all'interno, fondamentalmente; non c'era nulla, o meglio... nulla di interessante o di originale.
Vi si trovava tutto quello che non era più possibile trovare in televisione:
quindi, o si andava ad aprire i cassettoni del mobile di tua nonna per cercare tra le videocassette della tua comunione e delle tue recite a scuola
qualche video musicale che magari si era riusciti a registrare da MTV o da All Music;
oppure lo si doveva andare a cercare su Youtube. E poi circolava quella leggenda metropolitana (che ancora adesso aleggia sulla piattaforma)
di questi fantomatici "video con I gatti", sulle quali le persone nel 2017 si chiedono ancora: "ma è vera questa cosa qua?
Esistevano veramente così tanti video di gattini..?"
Santo Padre Pio, se c'erano un sacco di video di gattini, mannaggia la puttana..!
Però, mentre cercavo l'ennesimo "music video + lyrics" dei Coldplay, mi imbattei in un piccolo cortometraggio chiamato "Rubber Johnny"
(che in realtà non risulta essere proprio un cortometraggio, quanto una via di mezzo tra un video musicale e un cortometraggio).
Prima di spiegarvi effettivamente cosa sia, ve ne mostro un piccolo spezzone.
[Musica distorta in sottofondo]
"Con Yotobi, solo il meglio dell'allegria per tutta la famiglia!"...
"Rubber Johnny" tratta, appunto, di questo ragazzo di nome Johnny che presenta delle malformazioni, e il quale si ritrova chiuso in una stanza.
Guardando il video (che comunque rimane aperto all'interpretazione soggettiva dello spettatore - quindi potrei tranquillamente sbagliarmi nel affermare questi pareri)
a quanto pare qualcuno (forse la madre o il padre) lo tiene rinchiuso lì dentro, non volendolo far uscire.
E allora il regista Chris Cunningham cerca di far capire allo spettatore quanto questo ragazzo vorrebbe fuggire da quella situazione di prigionia.
E come la fa comprendere, questa cosa? Magari con lui che tenta di aprire la porta, oppure mostrandolo mentre piange in un angolo..?
Macché: ovviamente cercherà di farlo comprendere utilizzando delle immagini psichedeliche ad altissimo voltaggio e molto veloci, condite in sottofondo da delle musiche
(anch'esse psichedeliche e riprodotte in alta velocità di Aphex Twin); e da quel che si evince, lui tenta di fuggire appunto da questa stanza
sbattendo più volte la testa contro le pareti, contro il pavimento...
Perché alla fine è un ragazzino, ed essendo un ragazzino che non è mai stato in grado di muoversi fin dalla nascita
(e che, magari, non ha neanche visto nient'altro che non siano le quattro pareti di camera sua dove viene rinchiuso)
e quindi la sua fantasia funziona in un modo diverso rispetto a quella degli altri. Adoro l'idea centrale che sta alla base di questo cortometraggio.
E poi, vuoi mettere gli incubi che ti procura..?
Dai..!
Ma per essere un'idea che mi susciti curiosità, essa non deve risultare essere per forza trattante un argomento pesante come il suicidio, come il voler fuggire...
Può trattarsi anche di qualcosa di molto più semplice, come il fare "coming out":
Guglielmo, per esempio, sul suo canale ha realizzato una cosa immediata, diretta, incredibilmente semplice ma non banale.
«[...] il sushi, libri il rumore della pioggia, il cazzo, Londra, DnD, [...]»
Quella risulta essere un'idea piccola, ma buona.
Detto questo, dopo avervi presentato questi esempi... La domanda che mi potreste porre sarebbe: esiste, per caso, un'idea di qualche progetto un po' particolare
che, dopo averla scoperta, mi ha lasciato un segno indelebile nel cervello..? Della serie, che non la riesco più a cancellare, non la riesco più a "scartavetrare" via dalle meningi,
e alla quale mi ritrovo a doverci pensare almeno una volta alla settimana, a questa maledetta idea..?
Be', la risposta è sì.
Vi riporto nuovamente indietro con la memoria; perdonatemi tutti questi "viaggi temporali", ma oggi mi va di fare così. Grande Giove!
Desidero riportarvi indietro al periodo del Bluetooth (della scoperta del Bluetooth) e dei primissimi Smartphone
(che probabilmente erano dei modelli non potevano ancora essere considerati davvero come Smartphone)
con cui però ci si poteva scambiare senza l'utilizzo di fili (era una roba incredibile, per il tempo) dei file.
In quel periodo, a quanto pare, ovunque tra le persone del tempo si scambiavano gli stessi contenuti, che sussistevano (più o meno) in:
1) le immagini di "Dragon Ball" (e quelle giravano tra i cellulari, manco fossero fatte di eroina);
e 2) un filmato che si scambiava tantissimo, in cui questo lottatore di arti marziali che si menava con una mucca.
Già questo risulta essere grottesco di suo; e siccome, nel 1999, Matrix ruppe i coglioni a praticamente tutti i film che vennero trasmessi al cinema in quel periodo
(che poi, da quel momento in poi, si è cominciato ad inserire degli "slow motion" girati con una telecamera a 360 gradi in tutti i film d'azione)
In questa scena vediamo lui che schiva, esattamente come in "Matrix", Il latte che viene munto e sparato dalle mammelle della suddetta mucca.
Come, mi chiedo io..?
Come siamo riuscito ad evolverci così, in quanto razza umana..?
Tuttavia, era una scena effettivamente divertente; poi, al periodo, ci sembrava tutto incredibilmente vero, "come la vita vera".
In realtà, se la si riguarda adesso, la mucca pare essere palesemente realizzata in cartoncino Bristol.
Ma che possiamo farci? Purtroppo il tempo, per quanto riguarda gli effetti speciali, è uno stronzo.
E poi, grazie al passa-parola e grazie a Internet, negli anni successivi siamo finalmente riusciti a capire da dove provenisse quella stranissima scena della mucca.
Ed è...
...tratta da "Kung Pow".
So che molti di voi staranno già ridendo all'idea che io stia parlando di "Kung Pow".
Del quale, tra l'altro, sono convinto che l'esatta pronuncia sia proprio "Kung POOW", perché...
..."PAAU" risulta essere lo stesso suono che viene prodotto nei film di arti marziali, nelle scene in cui la gente si colpisce in faccia...
POOW! No, eh..? Okay.
Le persone rideranno, perché questo film mi fu regalato e consigliato nel periodo in cui facevo le recensioni;
e mi fu consigliato talmente tanto, che nei suoi confronti sviluppai la nausea.
E so anche che, quando questo film uscì nel 2002, tutti i critici e il pubblico lo stroncarono. E ve lo giuro su Dio.
E considerando quanto Internet abbia influito nel modificare l'umorismo delle persone, che passò da "Ehm, non fa tanto ridere" a "Dio mio: basta Meme! BASTA MEME!!!" ,
"Kung Pow" adesso è diventato un piccolo cult, e nutre un sacco di pubblico fedele e adorante.
Questa parodia, tra l'altro, venne creata da una sola persona: il buon Steve Oedekerk. Non so come cazzo si pronunci: adesso lo facciamo dire a Google.
[Pronuncia di Oedekerk espressa dalla funzione vocale di Google Traduttore]
Dio mio...
Senza stare a rompervi troppo le palle, il film è una parodia di quelli di arti marziali. Bella lì, ecco detto.
E, quindi, perché questa immondizia dovrebbe essere una rappresentazione di quello che io considero essere
una delle idee più semplici e geniali che non è riuscita mai più ad abbandonare il mio cervello.
Perché il signor [Oedekerk] non ha realizzato soltanto una parodia di un film di arti marziali.
No, no, no: lui ha letteralmente preso un film di arti marziali, vero ed esistente
(probabilmente di pubblico dominio, uno di quelli di cui nessuno possiede più i diritti d'autore,
quindi è possibile trovarli in vendita nei mercatini dell'usato al prezzo di 50 centesimi - con scritto sopra, magari, "I grandi classici delle arti marziali")
e si è inserito lui stesso dentro, per mezzo di tecniche del digitale, per ottenere delle scene diverse ma comiche.
Ha anche aggiunto scene con comparse, aggiunto le scene con la mucca (per esempio, quella è stata realizzata tutta in digitale),
ma la maggior parte delle volte lui si è semplicemente limitato ad aggiungervisi dentro (utilizzando lo schermo verde)
comparendo nelle scene di un film vero e realmente esistente di arti marziali.
Lui ha trovato questo film, "Tiger & Crane Fists" , e ci si è ficcato dentro.
Santo Iddio!
Questa, cari signori, è un'idea con i contro coglioni.
Io sto per piangere: finalmente sono riuscito a raccontarvela questa storia.
E sapete cosa..?
Lo voglio fare, anch'io.
[Voce di Karim fuoricampo: ] Salve, e benvenuti in questa breve video guida su:
"Come fare un girato su schermo verde, e poi toglierlo per mettersi in un film di arti marziali per fare un video comico".
Che risulta essere una cosa che la gente dovrebbe fare, almeno una volta nella vita.
Passo 1: prendere il vostro attore, possibilmente uno (1) Youtuber dal fisico molliccio.
Passo 2: trovare il film giusto; in questo caso, "Cobra contro Ninja".
(Questo film è di pubblico dominio, e lo si può evincere dalla sua ripugnante copertina - perché chi l'ha realizzata se ne è sbattuto, tanto chi se ne frega: chi vuoi che li guardi questi film..?
Altri elementi che rappresentano il pubblico dominio sono le terribili immagini sul retro della copertina,
il costo di un (1) Euro (€), con il quale non ci si ripaga nemmeno la plastica impiegata nel DVD,
e quei cazzo di adesivi che ti rimangono incastrati tutti sotto le unghie.)
Passo 3: scrivere la sceneggiatura; cercate di usare tutte le vostre doti artistiche per tirar fuori un capolavoro.
(Anche scrivendo lettere a caso - tanto non è un vero tutorial, ragazzi: è un video comico, quindi non rompete le balle, dai.)
Passo 4: lo schermo verde; impostare uno schermo verde non risulta essere così semplice come possa sembrare.
Occorre trovare il colore giusto, che non sia né troppo verde/sfumatura foglia, né troppo verde/sfumatura cadavere.
E' necessario posizionarlo all'altezza giusta, perché un telo troppo alto potrebbe tagliare via dall'inquadratura i piedi; e un telo troppo basso potrebbe tagliare via dall'inquadratura la calotta cranica.
Pertanto, si deve cercate di regolare al meglio tutto quello che -
[Rumori metallici molto acuti]
L'ho pagato 15€ dal negozio cinesi...
Sapete cosa..? Fatelo voi. Realizzatela voi una clip: so che molti di voi svolgono un lavoro artistico, magari lavorano nel campo della post produzione.
Oppure sono disegnatori, sono animatori oppure ancora di veri e propri registi.
Quindi, sai cosa faccio per Halloween..?
Realizzerò una cosa che non ho mai fatto prima d'ora; nella sezione della "Descirizone del Video" potrete trovare due contenuti:
1) un file, che voi potrete scaricare in Full HD di una mia clip girata con l'utilizzo dello schermo verde.
Se vorrete, potrete scaricarla ed impiegarla per creare qualcosa a tema Halloween, a tema horror.
Potreste inserirmi voi all'interno di un film; potrete creare voi lo sfondo; potrete animare voi quello che desiderate:
potrete farmi morire bruciato, dilaniato, inseguito dagli zombie, esploso da un elicottero... Potrete fare quello che volete.
L'importante è che questo video presenti una durata di tempo pari a quella della clip: quindi, di pochissimi secondi;
e, soprattutto, niente YTPoop, perché non c'entrano niente con quello che voglio farvi fare.
Una volta che avrete realizzato il piccolo video, potrete inviarlo al secondo indirizzo che troverete nella sezione della "Descrizione del Video": ovvero, una mail fatta apposta per ricevere questi file.
Così, mi potrete inviare il vostro lavoro via posta elettronica, caricandolo su Mega, su Wetransfer, su di un qualunque sito di condivisione dei file che vorrete impiegate;
o addirittura, se avete un canale di Youtube, potrete caricarlo lì in modalità "Video non Elencato" e mandarmi il link, così che possa scaricarlo.
E poi io prenderò le migliori clip con le migliori idee, e le guarderemo insieme nel prossimo video.
Eh, lo so: questa cosa mi si ritorcerà contro.
Cazzo..!